i have always thought that i understood
australia as a kind of fellow traveler
of the united states a similar uh place
with decidedly different mammals
i am less and less convinced that i
understand australia on the basis
that i see things coming across
media social and otherwise that suggests
a kind of
draconian shift in the australian
landscape
and at the same time
although i think i can interpret what
i'm seeing and i understand it to be
quite frightening i'm told by people in
australia that i've misunderstood the
evidence that in fact things are quite
normal and that i am uh falling prey to
a distortion
so i was hoping that you could help
me and my listeners understand what is
going on in australia relative to covet
19.
yeah look brett it's a it's a really
good question and there's a lot to
unpack out of all of that of course but
i've been saying to people for
the last few months the last few years
years even in australia um that if you
look outside the window in australia at
the moment you largely see the country i
think that we had and we have got and
i'm gonna say it and and your listeners
won't like it the greatest country in
the world here and uh but it is true we
have a lot in common with the united
states and we have a lot of things that
are that are terrific about this country
lifestyle um you know system of
government natural resources beaches you
name it friendly people all the rest of
it um so if you look out the window at
the moment in australia you still see
that um but the difficulty is that
what's going on
in that subtle space
of politics and of public discourse and
of course in our parliaments as well
gives me very very much
the reason for alarm and i'll explain
why um
as it stands we're still very similar
the united states and australia have a
have a similar but different path as we
know one of the great differences i
think though for australia is that
we were formed in around about the year
that you were fighting the american war
of independence
we were found the first fleet turned up
in 1788 in australia it was set up as a
penal colony the british
used it effectively as a way of parking
about 160 000
convicts who were brought out here for
the
heinous crimes of stealing loaves of
bread but our history is not forged in
war and fighting for our freedom like
the united states is and
my view is we're seeing the fruit of
that now the united states um fought
against the british and fought for for
its freedom and i think indelibly that's
been marked in your founding documents
the bill of rights the declarative
independence and and all the things that
go with it here we almost and i've heard
it said by learned commentators that
it's been said that australia was a
penal colony and has now come back to
being a penal colony i think that's
probably a bridge too far but certainly
we were always a country that
lived under the specter of of the police
i think effectively i mean that's how
australia was born a lot of free
settlers and certainly south australia
here where i am was a free colony set up
by private enterprise but
ultimately australia's dna is one almost
of being more compliant and less
libertarian i think than the united
states and i think that's where the fork
in the road has gone
so as i said as you look out the window
it all looks normal but what we're
seeing in terms of these protests
particularly coming out of places like
victoria
which is one of our one of our states in
the country here down in the south
eastern part of the country it's a very
artistic city a very erudite city um and
it's a city that has long had its
tradition for academic thought and all
the rest of it and at the moment it's
the city where all of the images of
strike breaking tactics of police
cracking down on protesters
um and a lot of the really really
hardcore stuff it's the city in the
world that has had the longest run of
lockdowns this has had 260 days of
lockdowns in the last period
now that means people locked in their
homes so
it's i guess to answer your question
it's a bit of a mixed message there the
the things that are happening in
australia are very real the things that
are happening even if they're happening
once are very concerning and very
frightening there's a whole host of them
by the way and we'll discuss a few of
them today i suppose but certainly
you know the australia the liberal
democracy that is australia is alive and
well but we have to make sure i think
here in this country people like myself
and other politicians that feel strongly
about this that we keep talking about
the chipping away at the edges of the
fabric of this nation because it's very
real and it's very alarming
well i i think we've been through a
number of rounds of trying to assess
what we're seeing in the world social
media and regular media has a way of
putting
the most alarming things on a screen and
the challenge always comes back and says
you're being misled because you're
seeing you know where the protest is
happening where the crackdown is
happening you're not seeing all of the
normalcy on the other hand
um this bias exists throughout history
right even during wartime most places at
most times there aren't shots being
fired and so we can't reassure ourselves
too much the fact is
the agreement that we have in the west
with each other
is based on the idea that
rights are paramount and that they can
only be
uh abridged when a very high bar has
been met by government and i think many
of us myself included believe that the
bar has not been met in this case
and you know you joke about uh australia
being founded as a penal colony and some
people suggesting that maybe you've
returned there and uh on the one hand i
get that maybe that's a bit of an
exaggeration on the other hand i know
that today i was looking at yet another
video of michael gunner who i guess is
in your northern territory is that
correct that's correct and he was
declaring that uh
for
the unvaccinated only the number of
reasons that you are allowed to leave
your house is now down from five to
three you're not allowed to go more than
30 kilometers from your house
and this strikes me as both
punitive and i would say
uh it is all but obvious that it is
punitive it is a punishment designed to
force people towards
vaccination and it is also extremely
restrictive of liberty so
not exactly a penal colony but uh the
analogy is not that great a stretch
yeah and look
you're quite right that's a relatively
recent
development i think in australia but
it's consistent with a whole host of
smaller ones that have followed a
similar line and they all center around
this issue about
segregation this development of a
two-tier society of people who are
vaccinated and people who are not and it
should be said that 90 of australians
are a little bit more now have have
taken that offer up have uh have taken
the vaccines up so we're a highly
vaccinated nation we're also told by
so-called expert modeling and i and i
one of the things i want to see in 2022
is the use of data modeling and the
phrase data modeling less because it's
it's you know it's always
you know met with conjecture in this
case is true um but we would we were
told we would the country would get back
to normal at 80 percent well we're up to
90 now and we're seeing instances like
this in the northern territory i mean
this is outrageous behavior out there
and michael gunner is
i think he's a member of the labor party
he's a the chief minister from the
labour party which is a left-wing major
party um and he has made a couple of
announcements over the course of the
last six months in particular the first
one was the statement that
it was words to the effect of i don't
care if
you say you're not anti-vaxx but if you
are against vaccine mandates then you're
an anti-vaxxer you know so using that
pejorative language in order to
marginalize
and then yesterday's announcement which
is as you described it a an announcement
whereby
the northern territory is is effectively
reinforcing that two-tiered society it's
saying we're going to have a lockdown
that is people are going to be in their
houses but if you're vaccinated
you're allowed to go about your normal
business if you're not you can't go more
than 30 kilometers away from your house
you can't leave your house unless it's
in a medical emergency or to get
emergency supplies
i mean we've been saying this people
like myself have been saying this for
years now show us the evidence that
that's a reasonable statement because i
don't think there is any i'm pretty sure
you would agree that there isn't any and
we've seen this repeated all across the
country our state parliaments and our
territory governments have been acting
on advice they won't show us and
you know they have been quite
prescriptive in the types of
measures that have been brought in to to
stop people's movement to require mass
mandates to require vaccine mandates to
lock people in their homes
all based on science that they won't
show and that's part of the reason why
i've got myself into trouble i think
with some of our health bureaucrats is
because i keep asking for it i say show
us the evidence why is it that this is
important to have one set of rules for
people that have made a health choice
and another set of rules for another and
the silence is deafening absolutely
deafening yeah it is and uh i must tell
you i'm a scientist and i've looked
carefully at this and it's not that i
don't see the noise in the data i do but
there is nothing conclusive to support
the kinds of measures that are being
instituted
and i know that as a member of the west
our relationship with rights is
fundamental to our societal function and
the idea that bureaucrats most of them
unelected
are in a position to simply look at what
they think the evidence is and conclude
that ah it is the time to suspend our
rights and to behave uh in a way that is
most decidedly not consistent with our
our uh our founding
values is preposterous i know as you've
just implied that we need to have a
discussion
right there are circumstances in which
one does override liberty but those are
the most sobering of circumstances and
they require us to have an open
discussion of what the evidence does
imply and whether this is indeed a
moment that justifies that and i know we
didn't have that discussion here in the
u.s i'm i'm getting the sense you didn't
have it in australia either
which raises the question you know what
is this really about is it is it about
protecting people from a disease or is
it about uh
enforcing compliance at all costs
[Music]
you